welcome back to facebook now since i'm
joined by the piers pack
veritable trio of stars royal editor of
vanity fair katie nicholl play rotten
political author bonnie greer and talk
tv contributor esther cracker well
welcome to all of you um
esther
when you hear someone like hassana card
who came from syria nearly got killed in
syria for expressing his right to free
speech and protesting and then finally
comes here and then goes and works on a
covered board as a cleaner to give back
to his country i mean it takes a pretty
hard heart to say people like him
should be if they get here shipped off
to rwanda isn't it well the difference
is how he got here right i think he had
enough respect for britain to not get
crashed his way
via dinghy right well he gave crashes
away with a fake passport which meant he
didn't have to get a dinghy but he was
in the calais jungle and many other
people like him getting these boats
every day and they risked their life
that doesn't make it right and this is
the thing i think people often
assume that we're not compassionate to
people's plight to trying to get into
the uk but it really says something
about how you try and get into a country
if you have complete disregard for rule
of law look we're in the congress that
they're desperate people yeah but so the
desperate people in the uk we're in a
cost of living crisis people are people
are being taxed to try and pay for the
public services that we use to try and
take care of their families right and
the british taxpayers effectively signed
a blank check to let these people in and
there are no checks there no borders
there's none of that i don't think
that's fair britain's always had a
reputation for being as hassan said you
know around the world
uh for being respectful for being
accepting for being tolerant of the
limited there's so there is there is
there is and there are no doubt there
are some people i'm sure who scan the
system but there's also no doubt that
the majority of these people are fleeing
war-torn countries and we used to feel a
moral duty to take people in now we feel
that the only duty we have is put them
on a very expensive plane making no
commercial sense and fly them eight
hours and thousands of miles to rwanda
most people in britain feel really
uncomfortable about this no i'm sorry i
don't agree with this idea that we're
effectively shirking our responsibility
britain has always been a very generous
country but we're also a country that
has limited space and there's only so
many things we can do what about genuine
asylum seekers genuine refugees that go
through a legal process to try and come
to the uk and we realized that we were
out of budget because we're having to
you know put these people in hotels that
have effectively come here via dinghies
from france they're not exactly escaping
a war-torn country they're coming from
france doesn't mean they're not escaping
water
no
they are they just happen to have got to
france i want to come to the uk you're a
genuine asylum seeker you go to the
first safe country that you you arrive
in what is wrong with france it's
nothing but what do they want to come to
britain well you know you don't get a
choice you say we're not absolutely okay
well bonnie i mean the argument we're
not absolving our responsibility and
they should all stay in france or we
send them to rwanda i don't hear much
from that side of the argument saying
actually we should take a lot of these
people in because they come from
countries which in some cases we have
bombed well you know quick things i mean
there's a lot to say but quickly um a
lot of people young people learn english
that's their language this language of
business it is the international
language so they got no business in
process they're not gonna be able to
speak the language okay that's number
one number two one ceo said to me a guy
who makes his way across a desert gets
on a boat a raggedy boat makes it across
the mediterranean gets across france and
gets here i might want to interview him
for a job
this is a deprising dude and the third
thing is and and i i think it's quite
shocking
what's not taught in this country is
that everyone in this country is either
an immigrant or descended from an
immigrant so therefore there should be
basic understanding of immigration and a
basic tolerance of immigration i agree
you know we have to deal with you know
with with the country i mean obviously
you have to control your borders
i mean that's a national you have to
have a regulated immigration but there's
a myth in this country that this country
is somehow not an immigrant country this
is an immigrant but the country and not
only that is that as you said in world
war ii right before world war ii if it
wasn't for britain there'll be a lot of
british people here who would have been
in gas chambers if britain hadn't taken
them but the thing is what you don't
understand is for every migrant that
actually successfully makes it onto a
boat that successfully makes it across
the mediterranean and across the channel
there are tens of thousands of black
africans that are enslaved in parts of
the north african middle east that don't
make it across there is that not just
it's not just about the exactly is that
is that the reason is that is that your
reason no but hold on it's not just
about the individuals that you see that
make it across the dinghy it's the
actual economy of people smuggling that
you don't see them
so why don't we go and deal with that
here's why i do have some sympathy with
the argument is that there's no doubt
that our efforts to stop these boats
coming have not only failed the
situation has got steadily worse there's
also no doubt that if you don't manage
immigration properly you're going to get
parts of the country where they feel
like way too many people have come in
way too much pressure on the
infrastructure schools services and so
on there's no doubt those things can
also be true
as well as thinking that we should not
be sending people to rwanda well the
answer becomes if it's not rwanda well
what is the would you have a problem
exactly and that's my point you know to
say that suddenly we do this and that
action happens we didn't have a chance
as a body politic to even ask why this
particular country we didn't have a ch
even the tory party is saying it is
immoral to actually export our
immigration situation
i get told for example that it's you
know rwanda terrible place blah blah
blah and then i remember that my
football team arsenal the shirt sponsors
are visit rwanda
because the president of rwanda is a big
arsenal no it's not and he's they pay 10
million pounds a year to sponsor
ourselves it's not about rwanda it's
about the country exporting
its situation to another country to be
it's not stopping anything we're
migrants we'll have to wait and that's
all right i'll be bringing this
on a different part of this prince
charles ignited a firestorm when
reported comments he'd made saying he
found this policy appalling will leak to
the media there's been no denial from
the palace which i think always means
it's probably true but there's not
something on the record obviously but
assuming that it is true i suppose my
question would be we don't know if he
wanted it out there or not maybe he did
but
should prince charles be getting into
any of these territories right now given
that he he is likely to be king sooner
rather than later and once your monarch
as his mother has shown for 70 years you
can't be political because the moment
you are you're going to alienate large
sways of your own people well i think
two things one we see how divisive this
issue is just with two of your panel
this evening right so for me and
feelings do run strong about this on
both sides
i know lots of people who feel the same
way
subject so for the future king to be
wading in however that may be and you're
right we don't know the context but
there hasn't been a denial um is quite a
divisive thing to say we don't expect
that a member of our royal family we
don't expect as a future king for
charles to be political in any way now
we know that the prince of wales is very
outspoken on a number of issues from
architecture to gm crops to climate
change i mean he once said when he was
accused of being a meddling prince well
if meddling is making things better our
medicine also his history has been quite
kind to him
calls that he's made she's been very so
that may not be the point you know maybe
the queen i know she has quite a few
opinions but we never knew what her
opinion was over brexit i mean she just
simply didn't get involved i think i
think that's the key isn't it it's i
don't think you can be a a king or queen
of this country and have political
opinions and we know that charles does
have political opinions and i think
there's something in what you say that
possibly he wanted this out because
there hasn't been a denial but i think
it's very dangerous territory i think
climate change or it is political he
might argue that this is a humanitarian
issue but it's got him into hot water
well as someone who's not grown up in a
monarchy i have to say that first of all
the guy should be allowed to say what he
wants to say i know he can't and i know
that somebody leaked it and it that he
hasn't denied it is his way this will be
his kingship he's getting us ready for
the way he's going to be or maybe
he won't but he's made his opinion and i
think younger people will say yeah he
should be able to say what he wants to
say i mean my every instinct would be
free speech he should be entitled to his
opinions yeah i don't want him to have
opinions the issue becomes should a
monarch be able to express political
opinions should you have a monarchy well
that well that's what you're adding
you're giving them ammunition you know
you don't want to have one and i think
the fastest way to end a monarchy is if
you have a monarch who expresses
political opinions on hot button issues
where you alienate immediately largely
is a child as you say charles is a child
of the 60s charles has always spoken out
charles is always only as a prince of
wales and yes
but he's still the prince of wales